In the previous sections,
any time we focused an element,
we relied on the built-in browser focus
ring to style that element for us.
The focus ring is great because
without it, it's impossible for
a keyboard user to tell which
element is currently focused.
In fact, the WebAIM checklist
specifically states in section 2.4.7
that it should be
visually apparent which
page element has the current keyboard
focus as you tab through the page.
But sometimes the default focus ring
may not fit in well with your design.
For instance, here I've got a blue
focus ring on a blue background.
So it's just really hard to see.
And in some cases, the focus ring can
kind of awkwardly wrap around elements
as we saw in our lesson to for example.
So we need a way to change
the appearance of our element, and
we'd like that change to happen
only when the element is focused.
To do this,
we can use the focus pseudo class.
The focus pseudo class only
matches when an element has focus.
To change the appearance
of our focus ring,
we can then use the outline property.
Here, I'm using the outline property to
change the appearance of the focus ring
to a one pixel dotted white line.
Now, some developers choose to
remove the style altogether
by setting the outline property
of the element to zero or none.
And this, by itself,
is a major anti-pattern.
Without a focus indicator,
how is a keyboard user supposed to tell
which item they're interacting with?
If you're going to remove the focus ring
because you don't like how it looks,
then you need to replace it with
another consistent focus indicator so
a keyboard or switch device
user can navigate your page.
Using that example from before,
let's look at how we can provide our
own alternative focus indicator.
So you might be familiar with adding
hover states to your controls
using the hover pseudo class.
Here, I've set my buttons to have
a red background with white text and
a text underline whenever
they're hovered.
I can actually see this in practice as I
go and mouse over the items on my page.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So a simple solution of
removing the focus ring and
replacing it is just to give your
element the same hover and focus styles.
I can do this by adding another
line to my block of CSS here
that uses the focus pseudo class.
And because the hover style might not
make it obvious which element has focus,
I'm also going to write
a style specifically using
the focus pseudo class.
This style right here is going to
remove that default focus ring, and
replace it with a colored box-shadow.
Now, you might be wondering why use
a box-shadow instead of just changing
the color of the focus ring,
which is a really good question.
Because the various browsers
out there style the outline
properties slightly differently,
just changing the color might not
always produce a consistent experience.
Using a box shadow here, I know that
I'm going to get a consistent focus
indicator across the different browsers.
Now, as I tab through the page,
It's much easier to tell which
element currently has focus.
Let's use the same technique to fix up
the radio group example from lesson two.
I'll start off by removing this sort
of awkward wrapping focus indicator
by setting the outline to none
using that focus pseudo class.
And then, I'll use a focus tile to
just target my before pseudo elements.
These are what actually produce
our little radio circles here.
I'm going to give those radio
circles a blue tinted box shadow.
So now when the user
presses their arrow keys,
it's very obvious which
item currently has focus.
So, to sum it up, if at all possible
leave the default browser focus ring in
place, as it's what many
users have come to expect.
If, however, the ring is
clashing with your page styles or
it's just awkwardly wrapping
around your elements, then you can
use the focus pseudo class to provide
your own custom focus indicator